[Music]
hello friends welcome to the lobby it's
August 30th I think is that today I'm
here brown I'm here with my usual panel
Mike McCarty is not back yet again thank
God for that
what's up John Luke pretty good we're
gonna get into a little bit more but you
went to quake on you survives
yeah it's actually like probably the
chillest like of all the events we go to
yeah it's pretty chill it's kind of nice
is that a resort this year yeah it's a
nice cool it was that this is called the
the Gaylord Resort and Convention Center
and often grape grape vine which is like
right next to Dallas Texas but not quite
Dallas Dallas and boy do they like to
let you know that you are in Texas like
every carpet just has like cowboy boots
and spread horses there's a like the
middle of it is this massive I know what
you call its it's kinda like this
courtyard area that's got like a sunroof
so you think like oh I went outside
today but really I was like indoors for
two days straight but they has this
massive just like a Lone Star just like
on the top and that night it just like
lights up yeah that's cool I lived I
lived in that area for like two years
and none of that is for show like they
all really do oh yeah enjoy that life at
least in that part of Texas that cowboy
life I've also got callyblackie oh hello
you did not go to another Pokemon
tournament I didn't I didn't go anywhere
thank goodness but I am going to pax
tomorrow so you all saundra John Luke as
well yeah yeah what about you Rob are
you going chillin I'm going to Santa
Barbara this weekend oh that's cool it's
in Santa Barbara my college friends
gonna drive down be fun sick well as
usual it's been a busy time for games
that seems to always be the case I'm
gonna dip back into the news a little
bit last week after the show Secret of
Mana remake was announced kind of
surprising everyone earlier that year we
saw that there was news of like a
compilation and for the switch right
Secret of Mana it's prequel and its
sequel we weren't getting that we are
getting this but not on switch this is
coming to ps4 PC and iOS
wait really yeah so square-enix joint
obviously and this is like a 3d remake I
mean hopefully it's you know it honors
the original where it counts hopefully
you don't have to doesn't have to be as
grindy this time around but um yeah I
don't know do you guys have any hype for
this I don't know if you guys like
Secret of Mana never played it yeah I've
never played it I've always kind of
meant to yeah and now I could actually
announce the perfect time because I can
maybe finally play the original since I
got ass Ness classic yeah oh geez there
you go you punk - I did - yeah Walmart
sort of buildup yeah whatever yeah there
was like a good hour - though where no
one was getting there like confirmation
emails are like okay it's all gonna get
canceled and then like they actually
actually sent them out so yeah
Walmart screwed me over the first time
and yeah almost screwed me over
you know when they opened up again but
yeah worked out I think we were the
middle of a stream or we record you're
doing like a let's play and like on the
let's play she was like Oh Rob I here's
my phone here's my credit card
we're actually not publishing the video
right mind I was I have to I have to
give another look it was the battle
beast simulator
yeah Giant Bomb beat us to the punch saw
that we were totally gonna do it that
one day we're liable to do it the next
day and then they yeah I think Dan
record tweeted but that game I don't
know it's just so ridiculous that like I
don't know if I try to look at our
videos and we as we all should like when
I watch this and this is like us
laughing and it's just the dumbest
looking game with like crazy peaking
audio whenever like if you don't know
the game basically you just like you
just take generic dumb 3d models of like
three crocodiles verse it's always dozen
dachshunds and you just see him explode
it's like not that impressive but it's
funny because it's so dumb looking and
like I don't know it's just it's a real
interesting let's play we did we're it's
just I don't know if someone would want
to watch that we'll see yeah just remind
the scenes
but Secret of Mana do you read the
credit card number out loud and
[Laughter]
personally start for that Secret of Mana
remake that game is pretty cool
it had wonderful soundtrack to Yakuza is
also very cool and there were three
Yakuza games announced in the past week
which is like that it was like that day
where they announced like a bunch of
personal stuff except is yaksa right
right so one of them was rumored yeah
cos at kiwami 2 which is the remake of
Yakuza 2 we recently saw the remake of
the original Yakuza Yakuza kiwami
but the difference between the sort of
methodology they're going with here
kiwami 2 is being made in the Dragon
engine which is the sort of modern
engine used in Yakuza 6 which we will be
getting in March I believe but they've
also announced let's see there's an
unnamed new Yakuza mainline series with
a hero that is almost in every way the
complete opposite of the main character
like the colors of his shirt and jacket
are in verse instead of frowning like
Kiryu he's mighty he's got this like
evil grin instead of having like really
neat hair it's like crazy hairs all
crazy
it's like he's its opposite day I mean
so that's pretty interesting
oh yeah sure it is literal opposite
colors yeah yeah I don't even realize
that yeah so I mean Yakuza games are are
great for many reasons but even myself
someone who's only started playing them
in the past couple years I've noticed it
yeah like I've played this character a
lot I've seen this part of Tokyo a lot
I'd be great to see something different
and I guess is it I am so pumped that
Sega is like really getting behind
Yakuza
well anyway and a lot of their series
that seem to have you know cult
followings or you know fan bases that
aren't like in the mainstream right I
mean like we've got you know Sonic mania
being a really good example of like a
series right I tried to make me extreme
they're like well look the fans want
this maybe we do with the fan turn that
is just Yaka up and down so that's
pretty awesome but the best announcement
was the Fist of the North Star Game
that they're making Yakuza games are
very dramatic and over-the-top and goofy
all at the same time Fist of the North
Star is also that and it's an anime so
it's very over-the-top when it's
over-the-top and very emotional when
it's emotional and that's what the oxy
team knows how to do yeah it's a
surprisingly good fit like at first I
was like yes yes yeah and if you're
looking at this trailer here like it
looks really good like there was a Fist
of the North Star dynasty warriors type
game a couple years ago but that you
know is very dynasty warriors but the
team is making those games know how to
make an anime sort of fit the visual
style and this looks almost on par with
that interesting of note is that they're
not using the dragon engine for this
they're using the older engine that is
sort of based on like you know ps3 tech
but that way they can uh Perez it to
1080p which I found kind of an
interesting choice but it works
god I love anime so much yeah right have
you guys ever seen the Fist of the North
Star American movie made in like the 80s
a live-action yeah live-action oh really
it's really bad so bad it's good like
it's really like the acting stare ball
like a is it like a drunk watch would
you just get drunk and watch it real
thing yeah maybe maybe a highlight reel
but I think if you have people who are
like really big fans and they want to
like just kind of laugh at something
really bad this is the like you're
already dead scene but it's just so
[Music]
[Laughter]
so good wait what do you mean it's not
bad enough to be good I want to watch to
you then maybe get drunk with some
friends and watch that [ __ ] sober yeah
and so anyway the no release didn't any
of that stuff it's all up in the air but
we have Yakuza 6 to look forward to and
you guys should play kiwami if you
haven't played Yakuza the hell is right
I think I'm gonna finally do like a cuz
I've never played the series which is
like a crime I feel like for me
personally and I I think I'm gonna
finally like you know arrest yourself
and yeah I'm gonna play them all now yes
I yeah now that I have the ability to
play them all I feel like in a
convenient way like that's always good
what kind of got me was like well ok I
have to get like a ps2 and I absolutely
fine copy opposite one opposite too but
now that we have you know 0 and Q ah me
1 and 2 and then it's much easier for me
to play like 3 4 & 5
yeah we have copies of those in the
library so I think I might finally do
that you don't have a copy jock is a 5
it's digital only man okay well crime
alright yeah any yeah cos interest from
you Kelly
I feel like you would like oh I would
absolutely love them they've been very
popular in my house lately I'm okay my
housemate is playing and so I've been
watching through Moses yeah one of my
favorite scenes is when he like super
dramatically answers the phone and it's
like I also love that we aren't calling
it Yakuza right because there's
something about that that arrangement of
sounds that bothers me I get hurt - no
and when people speak of you could go
and they call it Ikaruga oh no wait oh
really sorry yukata guys the way to go
that's what works me the most I guess I
don't I don't know anybody we're like
persona 5 when they were like sakamoto
yeah Oh secret of mana
some people say mana I say mana okay you
say mana yeah like that one more also
why do we care so much
glasses yeah we all have glasses on
that's why I thank you guys for all
conforming today I appreciate it mmm all
right another news pudgy player unknowns
battlegrounds which I guess you have to
shout because it's an all caps
yeah for the first time that became the
most played game concurrently which
camera am I looking at this one the
camera the most popular game on Steam it
overtook dota now Luke that's Wow for a
period of time period of time yeah yeah
yeah it was crazy
we're just insane it's kind of notice if
you think about it yeah cuz dota is like
super popular that's like I think the
most lucrative eSport I think I don't
know where it ranks with League of
Legends but like making money right why
is but like this game is it's like in
early access which is incredible and
part of the appeal is sort of like that
jank like I'm trying to figure out how
to to cobble together a load out and and
survive here my vehicle is spinning
going mouths and I love miles from the
ground that person was disconnected or
something there we were trying to pick
up some loot so you guys have been
playing this to a degree at least I have
not
how has the evolution of the you know
the people that you end up playing with
and against you know since this game has
been ramping up if you noticed a change
well first thing you do is you turn off
all voice chat never hear that see I
don't play a lot of multiplayer like
competitive kids yelling no I know so
like when I get a game and I get some of
that I love it for like half hour oh
it's very novel for a little while sure
you wanna turn off pretty quick there's
been a some like controversy over like
stream sniping recently yeah watching
people's yeah but then some people
saying like hey like I actually wasn't
doing that like I don't even watch
twitch streams and then I'm just that
good and then them saying like well the
data we have is irrefutable it proves it
but they're not giving the data so it's
in this weird light
he [ __ ] he said she said kind of thing
we're like look I don't really tell like
there's no evidence either way and it is
kind of that's kind of getting a little
messy but and then the latest is that
they added car horns to vehicles right
and now it's like stream honking so like
just harassing literally like do it like
doing circles just laying on the horn
and so you know a lot of a good portion
of that game is is audio awareness and
yeah I just see streamers just like
these some copulation where it's like
cuts back and forth between these guys
who are recording theirs laughing I love
that and customers just like yes to like
quit or like gets extremely pissed off
when this case is - right where it's
like for anyone who has siblings like
once you show signs of you know right
yeah crying for that matter it'll
continue once once they get a rise out
of yet it's relentless right like yeah
so there's a lot of that going on a lot
of like community drama but like the
actual act of playing it is there's also
stuff with the microtransactions which
is because they're they've added like
loot boxes in the game and OH to get
cool new pals it's like there's the
issue that one you're adding like oh the
miniskirt they're really expend your
adding these boxes to a game that isn't
out yet you know like and that kind of
gets a little weird I think for some
people I think a lot of people are maybe
you kind of over that now but the weird
part is the fact that they very
explicitly said like we're not gonna add
that and then kind of going back on
their word now maybe just a more of a PR
lesson for them right the practice is
more like you know when you're in early
access game I feel like you have to kind
of handle that really delicately in an
especially a game where this many people
are playing it's kind of easy to step on
people's toes and maybe they've got been
fumbling a little bit with that no
people are pretty passionate about this
game yeah yeah and it's probably got a
long ways to go still until it's in its
final version like what else is gonna
change how is that gonna piss off or
Pleiadian let's the problem the real
axis is like people expect it to both
change
Klee because it's an early access but
they also don't want it to change too
much because then it stops being the
game they love like Minecrafts like a
perfect example like that's pretty early
access but I remember like oh man I
played the beta exactly we're like we're
adding cake and I was like yeah you're
like well screw this game now sucks Oh
cake I was making a glass house and I'm
super excited about it
I didn't wanna deal with cake I remember
I remember being yeah we were being
really upset that's like such a good
really example of that kind of stuff
like before it really exes with the
thing just like oh yeah I totally had
like friends who like played it in the
beta and really God sucks now like they
they've had to too much and there's a
good tutorial so like it's garbage I
thought the game I remember I do want to
just go back to the actual numbers part
of those like that having the highest
concurrent player count it I think that
the coolest thing the thing I'm but I
like about pub G I think one of the
really it's one of its strong suits is
that it has a very basic premise that
pretty much anyone can understand it's
just like a survive just figure it out
and jumping into it is very easy but
there's so many layers to to getting
better at it and I think one of the cool
things is like you could have a really
bad kind of like not orangey but you
could land in a really bad place and you
have no weapons and all you have is a
car and a tank of gas and you gotta
figure it out and you can still pull out
the game from there and kind of
overcoming obstacles is a big aspect of
like setting up that game I just think
there's a lot of things that are really
easy to explain to the player to a
first-time player right but also you
keep coming back because you learn from
your previous game and so I think that's
just that contributes to the the high
player counts I think it's really smart
I think yeah I think the one of the
biggest draws of that game is how
quickly I mean for that genre right like
you know h1z1 did it all these are the
ones getting back into a game that like
super quickly he's is so me because I
remember playing a little bit of like um
well for instance like Ark had one which
we'll talk about later
yeah there's that like fear of dying and
knowing that like Oh like all this time
sacrifice innocent took me so long to
get back in the game 13 yeah yeah that's
a that's actually a really good
comparison really like you know that
permit deaf more or less yeah that game
also made you wait like if you die you
have to over yeah you wouldn't be able
to redeem the experience right they
never fix that or like I don't know I
gave up gave up on that game so long ago
but like but the whole thing we're like
if I died right away I and my friends
are still playing I would you feel like
alright I guess I'll just go like make
dinner or something right like we're a
but don't leave because you might get
revived as Jason exactly it's like
random character yeah where whereas you
with pubsey it's more of an immediate
like okay I learned a thing I can wait
for my team or we if we died really
early we can all just exit and try again
yeah that's what my favorite tactic in
that game is um I like going to the
school which is just as high traffic
area and so when you get there you'll
like be landing on the roof and it'll be
like 20 other people landing on the roof
and I kind of love that because you get
that like instant gratification of like
just let's do this let's like no one has
guns yet you're just running for the
nearest like shotgun and chances are
you'll die pretty quick but if you make
it out of that you're like dude I can do
anything at this point like there's and
if you die it's like oh whatever
it was like two minutes it was kind of
fun and I can get right back in it and
like as opposed to like and there's also
something satisfying about like landing
in a quiet area and trying to like
really like play the long game but like
I could be a little boring so there's
something this game like also appeals to
that like instant gratification as well
if you just want that which I think it's
like cool cuz it gives you options and
how you want to approach it and I keep
hearing about how you don't you know if
you're new the game and you you want to
you know not necessarily like level up
alike you don't want to play so
conservatively because because when you
then get to those height Angelou's
shooting moments
you're gonna lose so like that's like a
good approach like alright I'm just
gonna like perfect my gun game yeah yeah
my first game I didn't encounter anyone
for a really long time and I survived
until they were like 40 people after
something and and then the I encountered
someone who died right away whereas
I had just like gone to the school and
dropped in for my first game and just
been like all right how do had a
shooting work in this game so the
shooting is a little weird for games
that I play that would have been a
better use of my time I just think
there's a lot of things that keep people
coming back and also make it easy for
new people so you pick up the game did
you guys happen to see that thank you so
over the weekend again like the other
part of this game is I just love looking
at highlights they're so funny
there was this Korean streamer who was
on like I think that was where the
biggest teams like eight people I think
that right could you do it how many
missed the max number of people you can
have a nice like well anyways this in
this in this video the everyone on this
guy's the screen guys team had died and
they're all just watching him and he
sees like two cars full of Chinese
players were wearing red shirts he had a
red shirt and when you get to that level
of like a team size you at I you can't
actually see like there's no distinction
of like a name because there's so much
so many people I guess the max is four
we're like you can see people on your
team so anyways so he just gets in their
car and they don't need because they're
everyone's running around you pick up so
he everyone who's watching it on his
team who had died were just losing it
and he was this guy was playing it so
cool
so it's highlights I don't I can't
imagine how long it went for so he's
getting in the car and they're like kind
of looking at and he goes like there's
business you know there's a bandage here
or something like that and they like
pick up the bandage and then in the end
oh this is it
Wow Eric you're awesome whoa Eric and he
just gets in the car oh my god it's so
fascinating how this happened I don't
know if you can cut to the end of it it
might be a little too long time by the
end of it he just dude he just he gets
the moment he's in the bathroom and
they're all like huddled his room like
together Oh cooks a grenade throws it
and catch them all one dude is that this
there is like the only guy was lying in
the group is like in the end and he's
just standing there like baffled and he
just immediately kills him it is insane
yeah this is it
[Laughter]
10 kills Wow it was more than eight yeah
I don't credible isn't that amazing you
should watch that that's pretty good so
many ways to choose this game I love it
no man what is this game you're familiar
with uh what's that game son sundown the
boat game where you're trying to like
Rob you know I'm talking about um just
that video giant bomb did a while ago
velvet velvet sundae oh right where
basically that game has like this genius
like text-to-speech like raw and she's
everyone trying to pretend to be people
this game had that where it's like hello
fellow teammates right of course why
wouldn't I wait that's nice level
absolutely set up safe words with my
team like have the robots a banana
[Laughter]
basically the premise of this game is
you're trying to UM everybody has like
alternate objectives and you are
characters so everyone in this these are
all real players and they're all trying
to get other objectives so you'll have
like Boyle will like keep going up to
and being like hey I really need you to
like adopt this kid it's really trying
to get you over got this kid and then
you get like do like boils the worst
like screw boil like we're gonna go over
here and let's go make out in this room
and Boyle will keep coming and like be
like [ __ ] off Boyle sdcard say explore
data you guys man anyway anyway Rob you
mentioned Ark that's also hey wait no
it's no longer nearly access that games
out now one point out one point zero
after how many years multiple
consecutive years okay I honestly am a
beep axes with a giant t-rex I'm gonna
be real with you guys I have no idea
what this game is so I didn't either and
I tried to play some yesterday I didn't
see any of this oh yeah
said Kelly it's a robot dinosaure game
so I don't know a whole I've I've played
you know you you actually do start so
it's it's one of these survival games
this is not super late game where you
know what I like about this game at
least is you know you start off with
nothing you're a caveman it's okay you
know it's got it was right around the
rust Daisy kind of rusty days with a
form of permadeath please now I have to
weigh it when you die though you're
always actually ramping up your
experience in your skill tree to like
create and learn blueprints so you're
kind of gave me as a caveman and the
endgame is basically like you are
looking at Robo dinosaurs and you're
building shotguns and the friend of
course I want to befriend an otter so
bad yeah she's don't for you right so
they kill the bird mom good the world is
filled with dinosaurs and animals and
stuff and they're out to kill you what's
your take on it you said you played it
when it was still in early access and
then you tried it again now that it's in
what like it's 1.0 um I don't have a
strong opinion I've been enjoying it um
it's it's kind of neat to like keep
going back and and knowing that if I die
cuz it's something like Daisy gets
exhausting were you putting like I've
had runs which is like like it feels
like two three hours I need I yeah and
then what nothing like here at least
you're you're getting back into it after
dying and it's been fun I like I like
survival games a lot I like the idea of
like cooking me and coming back to a
campfire and this is where I cooked that
meat that one time during the night it's
super super scary dude okay so when I
started playing yesterday it started me
off in the middle of the night
pitch-black
yep every single fire I walked off to
was owned by another player
hmm so I couldn't use that fireplace I
couldn't make my own fire ruff life the
only thing I could find was Dodos so I
was punching Dodos single-handedly
trying to recreate their extinction but
you need to eat some food sounds like
okay so I found some berries and [ __ ]
I've eaten it it's like you just need to
eat food I I couldn't do any I couldn't
get anywhere so - so - see and literally
I'm a naked dude on a beach with like
nothing around right twigs normal
Tuesday so to see that sort of yeah
that's sort of like it looks like it's
almost like a our environment
manipulation like going on when that guy
was right in the dinosaur and like doing
like weird like how does it get to that
point it's yet time I mean you are
always like automatically the more you
killed more you do things you're always
gaining experience and you're just you
know and then you can put it into
different areas I can you know I can
also get like points put in like
basically my stats as well as like
blueprints and trees and stuff so you're
always you're always in the more you
play the easier get so like I had a
similar thing because I had to like I
mean again I played this a year or two
ago coming back to it I had to relearn
that as well like I died like three
times before I was like okay I have to
like really quickly make a hatchet
chopping down trees making a spear
killing animals quick quicker making a
campfire
yeah like close like every time you get
back into it you're doing those steps
quicker and easier yeah so they're also
the point where like you can make a bed
so this is I think a big a big turning
point I haven't done that yet so when
you die you can warp right back to your
house so you're going back and so you
then have storage boxes which have all
of your also you know progress and like
okay cool now I don't have to make these
hatchets anymore because I have five
that I made already which do you reach a
point where you can respawn or like once
you have a house you can respawn you
have to have a sleeping bag to to
generate a spawn point gotcha - or also
your spit out randomly okay so once you
like hit a certain point it's like
cocaine I don't have to do this early
game stuff anymore we're just very nice
cuz there's so many games where like I
don't know
it could get really repetitive yeah and
lean on enjoyable yeah where if you get
really good at the the the beginning
of the games you have to play it all the
time and then like every time you get to
a point and like oh I got a little
farther this time but I died again and I
got to start over it's nice that there's
like a oh I can put a stake in it here
mm-hmm
say all right I don't have to do that
part anymore yeah yes I really want to
get myself a more advantageous to start
somehow that is good I'm just super
curious about that moment when it
switches from primitive to future tech
see the tree yeah it's like shotgun like
at some point you build it in the
shotgun
I love tech trees its suit like that's
like I want to say that's like like
level or two like you know you have just
like hatchet six would be shotguns I
think it goes onto like 50 like dang it
really yeah probably you mean you saw
those dinos that's a futuristic Death
Star yeah W that's like a Gurren Lagann
level of like just like ramping it up
ramping it up totally in a period of
time we live in holes and then now we're
in space anime and like at the beginning
they're just like literally like living
in holes like digging with like tiny
little like hand drills and never seen
daylight and they lay by like the end of
like 25 episodes there don't spoil it
but you call it ghost place basically
you find bigger and bigger drills no
it's a great show watch it but yeah so
we like it's it's out of early access
right it's got 1.0 maybe it's a 1-point
no we've actually got collector's
editions we're gonna give away at the
end of the show but I will say that like
I kind of had a similar start like but
the more I play the more I'm learning
new things like berries certain berries
have perks
so I finally like know to eat this berry
I can run faster I feel like or some of
them will put you to sleep
the I'm so hungry but
[Laughter]
genitalia in this game like in a Conan
or rust like would you ask him sorry
their wieners the character no the
character creation is ridiculous that
text up top
ridiculous the short answer is no yeah
this is oh no wieners UI stuff is is I
feel like really tedious and it's super
dense that was the game doesn't really
introduce anything to you it just sort
of like here's all these menus yeah I
told me go to your inventory to level up
I took me like five minutes being like
Zach where where is it in Tori to a
level up it makes sense one with two and
now it has this thing which like you you
get you know get these blueprints right
like you have at some point you have so
many blueprints that you can like create
folders yourself but it's just weird to
like be it looks like I'm looking at
like a Windows like the same as
explorers yeah it's okay where and I'm
like going through like you know
miscellaneous or weapons or melee and
it's like you're going through all these
things this game is also like you know
you pause the game like you're always in
danger
so there are times like like yesterday
we're it's like the middle of the night
I'm trying to like find how to build a
campfire here clawing my face dead
immediately
really good did yeah that's good well I
I want to try this game because I like
dinosaurs I like surviving I love tech
trees the most I'm interested despite
all the menus I feel like that's
something you also learn as you play for
sure like this tedious but like it it
got to the point where like I knew it
was you know the more you play the more
like you feel like you're achieving
something every life because you will
die definitely yeah I've been kind of
liking as well there's nothing like
really fun about it or at some point I
just really want like man to tame like a
t-rex and ride that around I got saw
some people riding dinosaur it was like
I want to be you
[Laughter]
I think is one of the big appeals of
these games is like you get that point
where you can then go back to the guy
who is like trying to eat berries or
like trying to start a campfire and you
run up on a status or you're like hey it
gets better have this for free or you
see because there's always an ongoing
chat for people in the service or ISA be
like I just killed one of these noobs
boy you see these like scenes or
scenarios like in the chatters like
harassing them right so given all that
how will this play on console do you
think that's good not even like from a
technical perspective like in terms of
graphics but in terms of like how do you
manage all this [ __ ] that's a really
good question I wonder what what that's
like
cuz there's a again like you were always
in danger for the most part it feels
like so like you have to be real quick
with that menu system I wonder how it is
on a controller even yeah yeah well we
should have a review up on GameSpot soon
we've got our Friedan interviewer slash
real life mayor Brett Todd working on it
he's a mayor's a freaking mayor I love
that that's why he does things like City
skylines reviews for us observer because
he knows instantly whenever I'm like on
Facebook and i come across his like
personal life things I'm like I really
want you to be working on that review
but it's okay to you're in a town-hall
meeting talking to your constituents
that's fine I get its so he's mayor he
likes to that's awesome I know that
that's kind of what I want my life to be
like I want to like work on a farm like
you know a lathe Luke Johnson yeah he
lives on a ranch in Texas he's another
freelancer he writes reviews he lives
like on his ranch like just like nothing
around the news writes reviews oh I hope
he's okay he was near the coast yeah in
Texas oh so oh god right yeah the mayor
uh-huh
is there a town left - mayor - soon one
thing I missed on the list when I was
going down real quick that was gonna
mention because it's weird as hell and
it's out today Final Fantasy 15
Assassin's Creed oh right crossover how
did it I was thinking about it somehow
assassin's creed keeps ending up in like
games
Ubisoft like published like right Metal
Gear Solid 4 a Soul Calibur the hive or
six had Ezio in it now this like how did
they keep getting away with that I mean
money honey I'm sure you know it
behooves both parties to to get these
deals done it this is weird
yes it's very weird I don't remember
Final Fantasy to be having this like it
doesn't climb it one start climbing
mechanics and I know yeah I know exactly
what now and none of this stuff is in
the game proper and it doesn't seem to
just be like little animation tweaks
like there's mechanical things in here
right really didn't exist even being as
hot being off the ground in this city
and exactly on the roof and seeing the
rest of it goes a banner to just said
Assassin's Creed on it yes this is super
bizarre and I'm not sure what either
like property gets from this fantasy 15
get something to show for itself I mean
they're just so disparate like I just
don't they really are understand yeah
but you know Final Fantasy 15 like you
know sure I'll set some people who don't
agree with me but its story sucks it
doesn't really mean anything really and
like the context of what you're doing
throughout that game is your personal
journey you and your friends I agree the
story blows yeah my opinion again
whatever road trip yeah but the but it's
like the perfect plot like the world
it's like a good platform for things
where they feel like they can inject new
events and new things into it and
that'll be fun to play because I like
moving and shaking about that world the
problem is they keep making these very
limited size things right like there was
the the weird like chocobo Festival
right also in the same town that this is
set in which is like this Soundwave town
it is weird what I call sepia toned and
like weird looking yeah you know what I
want I want them I want them to have a
nice Vegas trip I would play the Vegas
trip DLC there is like it's not quite
Vegas but there is that like place
outside of the main area that is sort of
like a it's got like little events like
a Coliseum and things like that it's not
quite Vegas though
you mean yeah you kind of bring up a
good point where you would expect any
kind of DLC or add-ons to be you know
changing or altering like the main parts
of the game right it sounds like you're
just consistently like okay I'm gonna
play this assassins creed for a couple
hours and then be done sort of yeah
excited distractions opposed to like oh
maybe I'll play the game again mostly or
something like that they have added like
a lot of changes in updates okay so like
mechanically in terms of technically how
camera stuff works like how combat
things will link together even the
ability to like get like a piece of
armor that'll give you half an hour's
worth of invincibility every day stuff
like that so they are they are giving
you some things even vehicles as well
can go off-road now or before you were
stuck okay yeah so there's some they are
making those changes as well but they're
not huge the big one if it works is
gonna be Final Fantasy 15 on line which
you try which we tried and we couldn't
get into and even the footage I saw of
Miguel getting in it didn't even look
that that interesting I'm sure that what
they were offering was really just a
technical service I would love to see
that because that has the potential to
become like a grand theft auto 5
scenario where the online like
potentially eclipses the single player
right you know like they're still making
stuff for like quick like they've made
like a pub G style thing for GTA now oh
yeah like they just keep putting out
something at this point like if I was to
go back to Grand Theft Auto 5 I never
beat the the campaign but I mean like I
was but I'd be like maybe I would just
play the multiplayer because it just
seems like there's so much to it now
there really is I think to the point
where it's intimidating right I mean it
always was intimidating there's just
that open world like when you've played
a bunch so for you to say that is
something yeah cuz it was I mean they
they're really good act like continually
updating that game like um yeah to the
point where it is a little intimidating
works I don't even know like what much
like grind tours like what's because a
lot of it I remember looking online
would like it would it would be like
okay what's the best mission to play in
order to like get the bigger the most
reward out of yeah cash and I don't know
like now there's so much going on and
the whole point of that is just like do
whatever the hell
you want like that's what that's that's
what I always liked about GTA when I
would like like GTA 3 or something I
just loved that I could just like do
whatever the hell like I'm just gonna
run my car and these people just cuz
suck it like I don't know like I feel
like grinding defeats the purpose I like
that there's such a high volume of
things to do that it's kind of like I'll
just do the thing that sounds the most
fun I guess
no I don't know I know you're absolutely
right and that's totally like a part of
it that's like the biggest distraction
right it's just like you know pretending
to be someone in the city but I think
we're or so I've been hearing is like
where it's been kind of fallen off is
when what if you when I told you that
you really can't do that when there's a
guy dressed as hit man with a rocket
motorcycle launching onto rooftops with
explosive rounds sniper rifle bullets
and he's one hitting you like [ __ ]
right and in order to get said items
it's like I don't know that'd be like
maybe fifty million dollars which is
something that is pretty much impossible
to brand for like your that's like
probably for what I want to say like 200
hours there's some like that I don't
know
Thanks so I don't know like that's where
I'm also intimidated this is to see like
this just mess of a city versus chaos
everywhere that was that was a factor
were like I got never getting a
helicopter once and like oh I put all
his money into it and at that point it's
on like it was really easy to shoot
helicopters out the sky so I got like
could never like fly around not being
just like me this guy you don't have any
flares or any like means of you know
swaying a rocket and it's just done it's
like whoa there go there goes my dream I
start crying cry baby go back to 15
though yeah I almost want cuz like 14 is
very mm Oh II and its structure but 15 I
think I like the road trip in the open
world that has two potential like can
you imagine like those GT a style like
role-playing servers but in like Final
Fantasy 15 yeah I'm a chocobo farmer and
you know that would be awesome I don't
know if the game can support that but I
can see what you mean like if you would
would be great yeah I would I would join
the BL server where it's just like we're
like the anime boys and we all love each
other we're going on a road trip what's
that what's that officer that you always
watch all the time Oh sheriff Eli
sheriff Eli like can you imagine like
the Final Fantasy 15 version of sheriff
Eli sheriff Eli as a GTA online streamer
that is like he's he's a retired cop
yeah I think was in the military as well
but like role plays a cop in GTA online
it has some weird mods where he can
actually arrest people and put them in
his cars so that's the big thing is like
console commands and like actually
modding like that that whole server and
that whole community would be nothing
without those mods right being able to
like be a cop and have like ultimate
power of like just arresting people and
dragging them around when they're all
stiff is gonna get a PC version but it's
gonna have mods to some extent and to
some cent and then I would you know plus
what maybe like two years plus change of
like perfecting that mod like this game
GTA has been out for what five years now
maybe square could just like build a
decent framework for their online and
then kind of let the community maybe
grow it and then I don't know there's
potential yes potential for naked
characters which I believe is the
current like hot thing yeah it makes a
lot of sense that's great how do I get
their clothes off the anime is really
beautifully like the animation is
readable in the the Brotherhood anime
know what there's so much I feel like
there's so many missed opportunities
with just like the boys on the road
don't worry they're making a weird
chunky chibi like super deformed version
of the game for mobile weird there is a
name for that style that looks super
deform I can't remember what it is no
it's this is like not quite the
traditional version of that Oh weird
it's it it described it's like they're
they're clay that's been squished and
like smacked on the table and pinched in
weird ways it's almost like a game the
tomorrow children oh it's not like as
far down the rabbit hole of weirdness
and abstract ness is that yucky head but
yeah yeah it's a bit it's it's strange
it's like concave and convex and we're
makes me uneasy cool so cool we're all
doing things we're not supposed to do
destiny to PC betas speaking of PC ports
that's out in the wild now I got to
place them yesterday have you guys
played anymore
oh definitely what are your thoughts I'm
curious primarily if well one if you
found it to play better on PC which I
think the answer is probably yes but to
if that means that you're maybe
considering not playing this on console
if you were already going to jump in um
I've been planning on playing this on
ps4 I was actually I played destiny won
an xbox and so I was just planning on
switching to ps4 entirely framerate
isn't just not a big deal for me with
this game or in general I just I it's
not something that I generally notice
unless I'm really looking for it so it
didn't really convince me I also just
there's certain controls that I liked
better playing on console like a weapon
like I don't know I obviously you can
remap it but I'm just more comfortable
with this game on console I don't think
I'll be switching to PC it's a mouse and
keyboard yeah maybe you didn't feel like
the console version was lacking when he
came to responsible like it was locking
it all and and I'm very comfortable math
and keyboard it's just I don't know
because I need it if I don't need it I
mean I played this game I played destiny
1 on console I like how the shooting
feels on console I didn't feel like I
needed anything else from it cool for me
actually I really like the mouse
keyboard controls like the especially
the precision is so good it actually
makes like this opening campaign mission
is really easy because the enemies have
been designed for a controller in mind
while on the other end the crucible the
PvP mode actually feels like way more
hardcore than it did on console like I
feel like that audience is gonna be just
kind of naturally a more competitive
audience than maybe on consoles yeah I
don't dig the crucible so I don't need
to that to be any more concern although
I'll say the one weird thing was um
your characters movement speed feels a
bit slow for a mousing keyboard like
like not aiming like literal just like
no yeah i just noticed that ii thought
weird yeah yeah i think that was a
factor of vibe so i was playing as
hunter what's the um the ability you
have where you can do straighter
dodge roll and for other things like
yeah like high mobility like like
sprinting and then like coming into a
slide like i mean again this is
obviously like you know my first like
hour with this mouse and keyboard but
reaching those keys and and felt like
disjointed summer so yeah like like you
know again you would imagine like okay
well maybe I'll move these keys around
like I'll have melee a little closer or
farther away or other things like that
but I kind of know as well I think
having the mapping option is great but I
just I don't know I feel like this game
was built with a controller in mind
anyway so it's not like it's the
opposite of like the arc problem where
it's like how am I going to manage all
these menus with the controller it's
like this game was already they had that
in mind from the ground up so like I'm
not lacking anything using although if
you don't care about PvP you can always
play this game with the controller on PC
you care about you know like the high
frame rate that's where all your friends
Lang I don't know you can't beat sitting
on a couch I really j-just that's not
something that's important to me with PC
and this is the kind of game I'd rather
play there's certain games that I'd
rather play on PC I don't know I'm just
not I don't need it
yeah I mean it would ultimately it's
great I think it's great that like this
was I was talking about Michael hi our
tech guy and who my client he was like
showing me like it runs really well and
this is a beta like you know like more
or less somewhat of a stress test right
like you'd you'd expect but like it runs
really well and even like lower end
systems like I think he said he was like
he never liked drop below 60 I don't
know setup he has you know so he had a
970 with a core i5 at 3.4 gigahertz I
believe and he was able to get
everything on high that's great
with the shadows on medium and he didn't
go below 60 that's awesome I don't know
why I remembered all that Wow
so yeah you know that's the whole
audience now that gets to play the this
game that's really great but yeah the
the big thing for me is just where are
my friends at and yeah that's where
you're playing yeah yeah I feel like
this is less about like trying to get
console players to adapt over to PC and
more just providing it for that audience
so ever had oh absolutely everything
like that's why I'm not married to PC I
totally I'm it's awesome that people
have that option if they don't but yeah
I think for this game the one of the
things that I didn't like about the
original is that I didn't really have a
group of people to play with and that
really put a damper on the experience
for me so this is my choice is really
gonna be around where my friends are
well we have an official GameSpot clan
we do now so you'll have plenty of
people to play oh yeah
on the console of our choice or platform
of our choice
oh so what so that that's interesting so
the the clan is multi-platform then yeah
okay
hundred people max it's just like stat
based stuff right yeah yeah so yeah the
clan is yeah it's platform base its
multi-platform so if you we get like
even though it's hundred people if we
get like an even number of people on
every console then it'll be pretty easy
for you to just like find someone and
that if you need people to play with yes
nice my understanding of the clan system
by the way based on I talked to mark
Noseworthy at e3 is basically that's
like a 10 points for gryffindor sort of
system where the things that your clan
are doing like it goes to an overall
score and this is my understanding is
subject to change obviously cuz the
game's on out but like you don't have to
necessarily be participating to reap the
benefits if your clan like if that makes
sense
I really I do not have a better term
than 10 points for trippin just the idea
that you know if you're on vacation or
something and you can't do your weekly
like circuit and destiny but your clan
is still picking up the slack I think
that's kind of cool if you're still
seeing the benefit
from those things even if you couldn't
do them yeah um which is a nice way to
get around the oh god I have to oh no
it's Tuesday and now I have I don't know
why you look on your wrists for Tuesday
it's Tuesday and I have to do these
things or I'm missing out and now I
don't have the best gear for next week
or whatever it is yeah it's pressure off
it's nice incentive to like create
communities and stuff like that oh yeah
definitely
thankful has them cool they're like a
house cup well I'm starting the Hogwarts
plan you know it's probably already made
yeah absolutely so not too much else to
say about the pc beta destiny to the so
destiny to proper uncon consoles comes
out next week we are almost there but
I'm PC it's like a month after something
like George 24th cover 24 six weeks kind
of nuts significant okay I almost said
it I didn't say it you know what I
almost didn't say the other beta that's
been happening recently is called Duty
World War two which we spoke about last
week but now we've had a chance to play
it then you guys primarily we talked
about war mode before which was that
sort of like you know the progression
based like multiplayer matches where you
have steps and objectives and you move
forward throughout a map right
tug-of-war brem objectives that you can
go for is a great way to put it similar
to battlefield ones operations mode yeah
so this beta was not so much that right
it was a lot of just traditional called
Duty multiplayer modes war was included
but it also had you know TDM all that
kind of stuff so how are you feeling
about those things now that you guys
have had a chance to play like I mean
this is almost like old-school Call of
Duty brought back yeah and you have to
hold it up against the more recent Call
of Duty's which have obviously been very
different in more modern for me I never
actually really cared for the mobility
aspects of the newer Call of Duty's not
because I don't like mobility but
because I always felt like they kind of
half-assed it like they didn't go the
full way like where it's like well why
would I play Call of Duty with mobility
when I can play titanfall be great Call
of Duty it felt like it's Maps never
like truly took advantage of mobility
the way like Titan Falls Maps did like
there was no incentive for me to use
that stuff well yes
especially like I played a lot of black
ops 3 and like though some of the mass
had wall running stuff like didn't I it
honestly wasn't very advantageous Oh use
case people could totally just shoot you
right up the wall and there wasn't a lot
of verticality to those maps to most of
the great map design was like neglected
whisper wall running exactly though I'd
rather have a game where they don't have
that and they can focus on making like
really quality maps however the map I
mean I agree with that but I was not
very impressed with the maps that we
played in this day I do agree there I I
thought they they were incredibly lame
based which I mean the the most recent
older Call of Duty that people would
have played would be modern warfare
remastered you think about those maps
are not super lame based they're a
little more open there's buildings you
can hide in in places you can go the
buildings especially this map that we're
looking at now this is what our dens the
the buildings are just built into the
lane so it's like you go in a building
and then you go out it's not really
there's no interesting way to to hole up
in a certain area like I found the map
very bland this one in particular I
really really didn't get Brault er
Gibraltar that's the like Italian kind
of Villa that one that one was and I
agree if you Kelly but I thought there
was when it was so very much like three
lane bait like I remember like oh my god
I just died three times in a row in like
the exact same spot yeah and even like
when I'm we're like gathering footage
and stuff and I'm looking at like two
hours worth of play and it just feels so
much the same like all the way through
even if that's if it if it's a different
mode like hardpoint
TDM like you just I just felt like I was
playing the same thing over and over
again and that that's what kind of wood
would have me fall off and and and like
quit the game when I would be like
alright I just did the same thing for
far too long but then again it's like I
know I feel back and forth because I
they did
they didn't need to change it up as far
as the cod frankly alright yeah I was
getting very much sick of that's ramped
up of like tech like what is this
anymore what am I like what is this is
this a person or a robot it's nothing is
recognizable I feel like it to a degree
it is it was nice it was refreshing for
a while to come back to this as far as
my experience with the beta and again
there's only three Maps I'm hoping for a
lot of maps and a lot of you know
different visuals and different
different types of like playing but I I
found a little like a little boring to a
degree I liked the map with the trenches
I thought that one was more interesting
I do want to say that the the map the
Snowy map I didn't like specifically on
Team Deathmatch I think it was better on
domination which i think is not the best
map design if it only works well in
certain game modes I think that's a mist
of I liked this map a lot I think there
were more other places to go I think it
felt less like oh I'm being funneled
into my my death you know I like the
shooting I like the weapons I like the I
like the divisions and I like the the
access to like your division locks you
into certain I guess perks would be the
equivalent of perks I don't know if
they're calling them that anymore
there's there's things I like about it
and I'm really excited for the
single-player honestly and this made me
more excited for the single players
because I think there's a good
foundation and you know that I like the
the sound design stuff like that I was
just kind of disappointed by the the
maps yeah I mean it for what it is like
it is a this is a very good like World
War 2 shooter like it's just to what
extent like do we want that I don't know
like enough for me yeah like there's
something about like oh I haven't shot
World War 2 weapons in a while and
hearing like that that clean you know
grand grand is like random yeah oh
that's that's you know really like
nostalgic and satisfying here and I
think that I think that's enough for
for this game for me at least it's more
when I think about like Call of Duty as
a whole and like where they go from here
I'm like I don't know I think you can
only maybe get away with this once yeah
it's I would say just it's again a cod
game where I'm just gonna play the or
I'm excited for the campaign I'm super
excited for the campaign that's all I'm
really like feeling like about this game
right now yeah I don't know how long
I'll be playing the multiplayer I will
give it a second chance and I get to
play hardcore I really hate playing with
a mini-map I hate it i hardcore is fun I
do not like playing with a hood or a
mini-map it bothers me a lot I hate like
being distracted by oh I see the red dot
now they know where I am I just I really
like hardcore is it as a game mode so
maybe if I got it until I hard core TDM
or something like that I'd like those
maps a little bit more and I'd feel less
like I was being funneled but so I will
give it a second shot on the multiplayer
I just I'm very excited for the campaign
campaign still sounds like oh we got old
war - are you excited you know I'm
curious about it but no excited it's not
the right word ya know it takes for me a
first-person shooter it takes more than
the sort of the the nuance like things
that you guys seem to love so much
because I'm not really embedded in that
like and I don't really love competitive
shooters necessarily for me like
something like doom which is just
automatically like such a spectacle and
and and like I need that I need a bit of
fancy Wolfenstein right yeah that
definitely helps definitely ups cuz
that's like science fiction and then sit
around with reality a little bit but
it's also a bit of war history
yeah and a Wolfenstein looks super cool
and I love like mecha and industrial
design and yeah just had so much of that
nice transition thank you for that cuz
we're gonna talk about quite kind
Bethesda's stuff so yes this man right
here was in Texas with all asunder feel
re they saw Mikami's latest hat he's
always wearing hats I'm assuming he
wanna oh yeah give us the full TriCaster
I guess you guys also saw games - like
something I really think that
is the most important thing if you can
slack I might be able to pull it up oh
sweet
[Music]
so you saw evil within - and you saw
skyrim vr dishonored death of the
outsider did you see any new Wolfenstein
I'm assuming no what he had Wolfenstein
but it was the stuff that read highly
praised you guys showed off a bunch of
that stuff ok let's let's dig into
Dishonored death of the outsider so this
is the latest expansion it puts I suck
with dishonored lore it puts you in the
shoes of but soon the shoes of Sebastian
Sebastian no wait no no no no no ok
Billy what's your last name
I almost said Lord thanks Billy Lords
now so Megan foster dishonored - was the
woman on that ship that you were hanging
out on like your hub area hmm and she
used to be an assassin named Billy and
kind of like renounce that that name in
that life and at the end of that game
they're like oh she kind of went back to
that and so you are playing as her and
it's kind of talking with a Harvey Smith
you kind of described it as sort of like
the end of the story they've set up
right with dishonored well not
necessarily the end of dishonored but
sort of like the the events that started
with the assassination of the Empress
I've come now like this is sort of like
the the conclusion the wrapping up of
that story and they're doing a lot of
interesting things with her as a
character by her being an assassin by
trade interesting you can like steal the
dude's face and disguise herself as them
walk past all the Hannibal Lecter mm-hmm
and like all of her powers are very much
more specific than previous games like
like this power she has a put it on a
rat oh you gotta talk to rats in this
game you could talk to reports arrives
when they give you
do some ratatouille they will give you a
little like hints and information that
could potentially help you in the world
guys going well we'll see in a little
bit there's a this cool ability called
Farsight which is lets you see in the
distance
I think it's called far sight far
something I think what it was called in
the first game but there's like that.i
ability where you can basically like see
through walls your Batman vision this is
more you like astrally project your
spirit oh cool and you can tag stuff so
like like like free candy flying around
and you can be like tag that tag that
and you can actually like go through
around like corners and you can see
what's like ahead of you I love I love
selling it as astral projection for some
reason I love that a lot it's actually
super cool Billy so I'm basically like
this guy here he's gave this a great
like verbal cue where he's like Oh make
sure the trap door doesn't you know is
closed so I'm like okay I need to find
where the lever for this trap door is
and I'd hate for someone to astral
projection way there this trap door and
yeah so I'm like using that's trying to
figure out where it is and then her
replacement for the blink ability is you
create like a like a ghostly image of
yourself and then you can astral
projection if you will so you can you
can set something and fall back to it
right yes within your line of sight so
you can place it down at any point and
as long as you're still able to see it
you can blink to it at any point mm
which is really rad and you can also I
didn't do it unfortunately but you can
if you do it on a person you'll like
explode into them like that like that
titanfall isn't kill although apparently
hurts you if you do it
take some help that would hurt that
would hurt it's not an easy task
that what was the well whatever was
called the one who said that you can
like warp back to like it's almost like
a
would you want to call it like it's a
good so it's a teleport right but I
could set something up and like approach
a room or scenario and it automatically
I like fall back to it yeah but you but
you have to still be able to see like
okay that so you can't abuse it where
it's like I'm gonna put on one side and
just like okay oh line of sight okay
open areas where that can be pretty
useful I think I sent it today we'll see
all right hopefully that shouldn't pull
the lever and then I just like yeah it
was cool just believe it yeah like
they're doing interesting stuff with the
because she's an assassin they've like
ditched the karma system and this game
like they don't have any of that it's
much more just kind of like do what you
want to do so that you're going to hell
anyway don't worry about yeah freeze it
up we're like I killed that guy but I
didn't have to kill that guy but there's
no wanted to kill that I wanted to kill
and it was really satisfying but there
you don't have the game telling you like
well if you kill him like you get like
chaos points and like right it kind of
removes those more gamey aspects and
just makes it sort of like hey man like
play it the way you want to play it like
play how you want to play this character
and your spirit will pay the price
exactly it was kind of big like selling
point for Dishonored 2 as a whole right
so even more so oh yeah because this
arts - you still had that system yeah
this just kind of removes like the
gamified like you know checkbox of it
but one thing is one was very much like
like punishing right if you just were to
go around you just kill civilians like
living right yeah well one would like
change the way the game works which is
cool but it did feel a little black and
white and where it's like kind of
putting you in like a box of like oh
your high chaos or your lo que hacen -
had that as well but it felt like it was
trying to like negate that and not make
it feel quite as like video gaming and
there's kind of goes the full like split
exactly then they had cool stuff like
you have a contracts now when you go to
the black market there's this board of
contracts and you can they're
essentially just like optional
objectives you can do within the world
you know to like kill a killer guy or
like find them and like get them
somewhere safe
stuff like that and those were fun
because it just gives you more variety
to like explore parts of the map you
never did before kind of get like a
better lay of the land it's just adding
more options within this these like
small like kind of hub spaces to like
experiment like it felt like a game
where I was much more free to experiment
because they've also they've removed
you don't need vials anymore to use your
your mana pool it just has it oh cool
it'll just kind of recharge so that
would happen a lot
yes with this week you're kind of stuck
right yeah and this it feels like
they're just like hey look just kind of
go nuts to do what you want like really
kind of get crazy with the
experimentation and I thought that was
like really cool that's interesting I
like that nice now you also yeah you
also got to play I think you got to play
evil within I got a play we didn't get a
capture it I have a little bit of b-roll
but it wasn't too much so I didn't like
the first evil within despite trying
many times to like it what was the was
the big issue there I felt like it was
for me there is a bow it really
struggled to balance its survival horror
elements with its more action elements
where it's like okay we're trying to
have limited ammo but then we're also
gonna throw like 20 dudes at you and
we're gonna take a lot to hit so it was
very much like unless they're doing it
exactly the way the game wants you to do
it you can very easily get yourself
stuck so this is the game so is this now
officially released because I saw yeah
this leaked I think last week something
yeah I had to I had to turn this demo I
gotta play and this is probably the most
like the first game in that it's very
much a scripted there's like banging
happening outside the studio spooky body
to the game go life's a game yeah he's
very much like a scripted sequence where
it's like okay I have to yeah this stuff
I have to go forward and I still see up
in a moment
you get attacked by this monster and
it's a really you know like cool like
set piece but
I'm kind of used to it from the first
game and I never felt in danger because
I knew like Oh as long as I sprint and
hold the forward button and get to that
door I'll be fine and it feels more like
a like a action set piece where there's
not much freedom and how I can explore
it which is why so that kind of it's not
bad but it it got more of the same but
then later on and fortunately we don't
have b-roll this it's a horrible selfie
[Music]
sowhat's see now I'm known I'm Tim the
tool man Taylor okay
I have to run straight and it's like oh
no I'm like my spirit might run out but
it's like as it turns out I had exactly
enough sprint to get to the door so I
never really felt in danger you know oh
if you make a small step maybe that'll
like that but this felt more like a set
piece and I'm okay with this because if
they use it more to just kind of break
up the pace of the game because the
majority of the game is actually like
these open areas where you kind of get
to explore at your own pace and that is
the really cool part about in this game
where you are
they have like safe houses you know like
I like Resident Evil and you can kind of
like go out of them and you have this uh
it's like radio that will kind of tell
you like oh this is your objective it's
that way but you have this whole town
that I kind of got to explore around and
as they're going through it you'll get
like other radio signals that are like
oh if I go over here there's some there
are these military guys who went in
before you and like oh there's a signal
from them over there so I went into this
house and I was able to find like a
weapon and I was able to find some ammo
and or experience points and just the
game seems really comfortable letting
you kind of like explore at your own
pace in a way the first game never did
and it was actually like pretty cool
because you get like these little mini
sort of like smaller vignette moments
where it's like I went into this church
and there's like a
and I had a cup scene where it's like
hey hey guy are you okay like you know
classic like horror just like so that
were there like inhabitants and like
that town like people that was a weird
thing like you're in this like-minded
dream it's like this uh it's basically
called stem is like they're weird
pseudoscience like name for this
technology where it's like a bunch of
people all connected to this like
massive like dream world
mmm-hmm but totally at one point you see
this woman she's like acting like really
really weird and like walking right he's
like hey lady are you okay
he's like oh I swear I swear she heard
me like and I'm just like dude like you
know you're in like this like [ __ ] up
dream world like and he's just like no
like this world plays by like standard
like logic and do it doesn't would that
be like an indication of like like an
enemy if like people are acting bizarre
like twitchy or something oh that was a
more scripted it kind of what to set up
the enemies but um yeah like I there was
like a woman who like called for help
because I go I've got to go help her and
then like you know turns like you know
that's a classic or a mistake yeah it's
like every I hate when horror exists in
a world without horror movies because
it's like like obviously if that
happened to me and I was in a weird
fucked-up dream world and I heard
someone calling for help I'd be like hmm
I've seen enough horror know not to go
over there right in a dream though I
feel like in a dream you are sometimes
not in control that's true you would
have like a motive for some reason like
it's pushing you forward you're like oh
it's a little weird because it's
canonically after the first game so he
very much as a call this is like what
happened before so I'm like yes you
should kind of know what's going on here
dude the we have an interview up on the
site that also under did with some of
the devs including Mikami whose hat we
still have not seen there is there we go
on that photo so I'm hoping I don't know
if you can you can you might not know
how or there's also not gonna take me
photos the sorry the guys on the right
where there's also the creators I'm
wondering if they might be the people in
the interview yes they heard the people
interview okay so I don't know which one
was which but Trent Haaga
one of the guys involved a lead writer
he has worked he's the guy on the right
okay so he's worked on horror movies
including with Troma mm-hmm as well
right
like toxic avenger they did a lot of
early stuff with Matt Stone and Trey
Parker like a lot of their weird
physical effects stuff and Shinji Mikami
has taken sort of an advisory role so he
is not like you know boots on the ground
doing the development he's kind of just
the visionary if you will but it sounds
like Trane Haga is very cognizant of the
fact like okay this needs to be pasted
properly we need to do this right we
need to have characterization like the
first day I'm like Sebastian was like
such a like kind of whatever character
yeah he had like very little motivation
for what to do this game sets up like
this very clear like he's here just try
and rescue his daughter and you're
getting like characterization from him
there are these you can find like these
uh like slide photos and like your your
safe room area but you can like look at
and you'll kind of get this like
backstory there's he's got a person on
the radio he's talking to back and forth
like they're there make very much making
a clear attempt to like make him like a
character that's like relatable and
identifiable and like so when you
actually want to see succeed as opposed
to like and the first one is like he's
grizzled cotton video game video game
worker right I guess I'll go through
with him like yeah you just you want you
want you want that personality just to
like let them succeed of course the show
was running a little bit long we got a
few more things to talk about so yeah
there it is there we go
tell me about Skyrim VR and why it is so
good and you can't stop thinking oh my
god it was bad I didn't I did not care
for it so what's the problem so we're
setting a game not made for VR yeah his
problems in video reminded me a lot of
um like the Wii version of Twilight
Princess where it's like they kind of
bolted this on terrain that wasn't built
for it so certain aspects of it felt
kind of cool like the the fire and the
lightning stuff we're like you are
disconnected you like you're not in
hitting a person like directly you're
you're kind of shooting fire of your
hands and that's kind of fun
but when I was trying to use a sword
there was no indication that I was like
hitting the person like there's they
don't have like alternate animation so
really I'm like swinging Adam
and I'm like am i hitting them am i
doing damage I don't know and and what
part did you play did you have to do
like bleak falls Barrow
yeah and they did disable certain stuff
like you couldn't open chests or like
loot bodies and they said that was um
more not because it was like not ready
they just wanted they don't want people
to like waste because you only can get
to play for 10 minutes so they don't
want people to like you know spend a
bunch of time like looting bodies or
like no we just kind of want you to go
through the experience and feel what
it's like in VR but like what I ended up
the most reliable way to like murder
dude like you imagine it with a sword
you want to be like you know oh I'm
blocking and I'm doing this I'm doing
that what I end up doing was I just kind
of held this sword out like this and
just kind of like spaghetti or something
and then they just kind of fell over and
died I was like all right cool like he's
dead in a way that like parts of it is
cool words like oh wow like I'm here and
I'm able to shoot fire to my hands but
for a game that already seems like it's
held together with glue and rice use
tape yeah I feel great I love Skyrim so
much and it's just not I mean outside of
everything you've said about how VR how
it worked in VR it's not the kind of
game I would want to play in VR anyway
and it's a game I'm gonna sit down and
play for eight straight hours and be
like I am the dovahkiin and like so
maybe like I I don't know how it works
but if it's the kind of thing where I
can play it mostly outside of VR like
normal Skyrim and then maybe like a
certain moment where it's like Oh about
fire dragon time to go in a VR like that
can be kind of cool but like not
extended like right time to go in for
like three hours and play this in VR
yeah that's a very good question
actually that might make the difference
for a lot of people yeah yeah yeah hmm
hopefully the cross save stuff works on
that any last final quick thoughts about
QuakeCon before i move on to mario +
rabbits now I watched the grand finals
that were actually pretty cool yeah yeah
great champions they have so they do
sacrifice
which is their team-based mode which I
don't really care for as at least as far
as um uh like Grand Finals go because or
in eSports because it runs them the same
problem I have with any other
first-person shooter where you're just
swapping between different team members
and you don't really get a sense of like
what's happening in the match or like
the back-and-forth nature it's kind of
hard to tell but with this is the 1v1
duals and that's really intense to watch
because it's just full you always know
what's going on and in spectator mode
you can see the other person's outline
so you always know like where's the
other person is and it's just this like
cat-and-mouse back and forth that's
really really fun to watch and then the
two people they had were actually like
it was it was almost kind of like
perfect setup where you have this guy vu
who has like been a retired quake player
he like hasn't played for like 12 years
and he like just came back this year and
like got all the way to the grand final
so it's like well it's like this big
return against the sky name Klaus who is
like a literal nobody like he came out
of nowhere he's like 19 years old he's
one they said he won like 270 dollars
total that's like his total accumulation
of money he's 1 out of quake and so it's
like this like perfect mix of like old
versus new blood right like which one's
gonna win wasn't that kind of the same
deal at Evo this year as well yeah yeah
right with blanking on the same curtain
yes yeah very much thanks hey although
in this one the opposite happened where
Klaus just [ __ ] smoked vu like
destroyed him like he had you know in
the evil one that kind of fell apart
because that dude was just like kind of
the pressure of it of like being in that
stage kind of like yeah they got him
like Klaus just had like he was just so
common collected and like it was funny
like in the UM like the pre you know
they have those little like pre
vignettes where they're like
interviewing them like he's just like
yeah whatever like well they're just
like oh like her you feel the pressure
he's like no it's fine I'll just yeah
like somebody who's only made two
seventy dollars playing this game it's
not like you're like I have a title to
defend or I haven't even play and like
when you're playing get someone who was
a lapsed player who hasn't played for
twelve years kind of like no I might as
well do this but like I don't know well
there's clearly we happen to the view is
like he wasn't playing as well as he was
the previous day like I felt like that
pressure got to him while the new guy
just like it's totally cool and
collected and destroyed it so yeah
that's actually pretty fun to watch all
right sounds a quick hums not bad not
bad
very very chill very fun very very Texas
the the b-y-o-see area bring your own
computer area is really cool yeah that
was nuts one time I went yeah they have
Klan flags up and stuff like that it
feels like a trip back in time a little
bit done it feels like you're looking at
like something from the 90s totally
those land rooms like a thousand people
yeah easy well that's all their
computers and rigs set up like in the
pitch black in this big ass room they're
playing they're playing like quake
they're playing pub G oh and all sorts
of stuff that you've no you wouldn't
even recognize right like weird games
that have communities and it's it's very
interesting and they bring their like
full rigs yeah there's a medic you set
it up the security process for getting
through with all your stuff like every
bit of equipment has to be tagged
because they don't want there to be any
theft or anything but what they do is
they you set it up at the beginning of
QuakeCon and then you can just leave it
there and it's a car we're just gonna
play until 4:00 in the morning and go to
bed then wake up and go back to that
room and do it all over again for like
five days and yeah awesome yeah
there's and and they're also like
hanging out with friends that they
probably like don't see in person yeah a
year so like this is like their
opportunity to just like kind of get
together and hang out and that seems
really really cool yeah it does seem
cool damn well where you were gone we
were playing Mario and Rabbids Kingdom
battle which freakin knew it the game's
awesome yeah he's really good Rob I
think you played the most at the table
Oh have I I think you have yeah yes
second I think I just finished the
second world okay yeah no yeah I just
got Mario or rabid Mario right all right
so what let's break down this game's
broadly speaking this is a tactical
strategy game not unlike XCOM in a world
where Mario's and Rabbids have seemingly
come together mm-hmm and
animation yeah I know it's this world
has all the wonderful like delightful
personality quirks that you'd find in a
Mario game plus the rabid stuff but like
it doesn't feel too much it's doesn't
feel heavy handed one way or the other
it's like it's a interesting how well
the mix of the two works yeah yeah I
paired of something like XCOM for
example which is this very like grim
gray you know aliens are trying to
destroy humanity you're a freakin
soldier here your cartoon plumber firing
bees that's something I really love is
is having that hardcore strategy game
without the grimdark right aspect and
and sort of how I feel about splatoon as
well as far as Nintendo takes on things
go just having like a a colorful more
light like I don't have to be like uh
we're all gonna die like it seriously
yeah it's even that goes a long way for
me or a mom that I don't like the grim
dark stuff sometimes but it's so
refreshing to have just like it's bright
everything's rabbit themed right right
and you will fail oh it's and they fail
in this environment it's less harrowing
right and that's the other aspect right
is like if mario gets shot in the face
he's not permanently dead for the rest
of your entire play right like he just
kind of like passes out and he has like
a little dizzy yeah I just I I think
it's it's a lot of people have been
saying it's surprising and I think
that's a little bit insulting to like
cutesy aesthetic I think we've it's been
proven time and time again that cute
does not mean not hardcore and I get
really really tired of people being like
I'm so surprised this game is good but I
think it was a surprising partnership
that turned out really well
I hear you here I think it is fair to at
least from my perspective it's fair to
be surprised to a degree because have we
seen Ubisoft to make attack talking like
this no no I think that's why I mean
that's what I mean the partnership is
surprising but a lot people are like
it's hardcore in a nice cutesy package
I'm just so tired sure it's not a good
aspect yeah
a good game like this so could have this
still could have had problems because
the things that introduces like this
whole catapulting of a character these
these like inter turn attacks while you
move those are the things that really do
elevate this game and if this was a more
like faithful XCOM ripoff I don't think
we would be as sort of smitten with it
as we are despite all the personality
because those mechanics really do make
this game stand out on its own terms
it's more than just an ex-cop like yeah
absolutely I I would say what was
surprising is like I actually don't know
the Rabbids that well so I feel like you
know at people were somewhat up in arms
it's like oh great like the Rabbids
they're the minions of their day right
like tarnishing my like precious my
precious Mario the childhood with four
jokes with fart jokes yeah it it's just
fine like I don't know like I it's hard
to say like you know it's not incredible
writing and lore and I love seeing these
rabbits they make me laugh all the time
it's not necessarily that but thank god
it's not like distractingly bad or like
really out of place with like Mario like
they played like really safely around
that right like they just have you know
Mario does or sorry rabbit will do like
a fart joke or some like that it's like
Mario's is like rolling his eyes yeah I
was one of those people who I don't like
Rabbids I don't like minions either but
I don't feel like it's intrusive
obtrusive that's one of those one of
those words is intrusive it's not it
doesn't get in the way of my enjoyment
like it but and it's it's yeah it's
really fun and I like these these kind
of open-world esque moments like that
cut that really keeps the pace nice
where it's like after a battle that's
relaxed and relaxed and thank you and
and I for one think that the puzzles and
they're really simple but that's fine
like for me it's fine like I wouldn't
want so intense you know block moving
puzzle it's really intricate because if
it was I feel like that would even be
more exhausting because right because
the battles are our candor yeah can be
exhausting themselves right like you're
really thinking about multiple things
like you know okay like man like I need
Mario rabid peach to get back over here
because Mario's about to lose all this
health but there's one of these smashers
in the way well how do I do this you
know I'll distract him with Luigi and
that'll give me time to have on my
second turn rapid peach be close enough
to do give the team health use there's
so much going on but it's not like
intimidating like the presentation of it
I think is like really impressive
because I'm not I really don't know
ex-con at all so I was going into this
like not intimidated but like curious to
know if I'm gonna be fall off but the
structure of like that the first world
it feels like it's very much a tutorial
introducing you Leia all the core
mechanics one by one I found that great
I found I was like okay I cool I'm on
board and then and each are
experimenting and you started learning
things on your own for instance maybe
one would be a little damaging one that
I learned the hard way was like Mario's
hammer he has because he of a secondary
as well as your gun Mario's hammer will
hurt your own team so I like annihilated
like Luigi by accident like how she's
and then you know you just dial back if
you want to restart the level or you
know you keep going forward there's just
a lot going on that's enjoyable and
first for the switch man like mmm-hmm
god I love playing the switch and
watching TV you can just put this thing
down even easier in the best way like
taking up just a break and not being
locked in say something like Zelda or
it's you know I would say it was very
much an immersive game that I wouldn't
necessarily want to play without
headphones but here you can't you know
yeah there's so much to say about it
that's enjoyable for anyone who has a
switch I think this is really great in I
will say with the
tactical element I was it made me
appreciate the Rabbids more because like
I really love rabid Luigi's abilities
and I kind of won me over and and
convinced me to give the rabbits a
chance I guess cuz like because he's so
useful to the way I wanted to play this
game I just think they they the they
blend the the tactics and the the two
different almost disparate second
tummies that were today franchises
together I think that it's just really
smart it's really it's really well then
is it weird to anyone else that you're
basically following a Roomba around the
entire time yeah yeah with ears so
Roomba with yours yeah it's like the
main character really yeah which weird
thing like Mario I was kind of just in
for the ride yeah uh I'm excited to keep
playing this game it's just for again
for the handheld aspect of switch it's
just so perfect yeah Mario poster
happens is great it's really good
I should go read admin trans review
that's up on GameSpot of course you can
always watch that on YouTube as well
lots of gameplay there we're putting up
guide stuff so if you need help getting
started you want understand classes
we've got you covered
go to GameSpot you can find all that
stuff today and in the coming days that
does it for the show
so we're gonna get into the giveaway
right now which again is Ark survival
evolved collector's edition we have one
ps4 addition to Xbox one editions and
this is everything you get you get a
quote-unquote leather-bound book I don't
think it's real leather mm-hmm
there you get some cards I think a
necklace and a map yeah I'm gonna rock
that necklace and of course you get the
game as well so to enter Shiva we'll be
tweeting and there should be a link in
the chat that you can click on the
contest is gonna be open until Friday at
12 p.m. Pacific time three winners and
you have to be a u.s. resident there's
only available to us
residents uh that's all I got
sweet here's every final thoughts yeah
right kick our asses out of here mmm no
all right well thanks for watching
everyone it's been a fun week Michael be
back hosting I'll be back in John with
Cher he'll be in the back room see you
then
and seem
[Music]